I just saw a shocking lack of honest and
objective analysis even former DNI will
even Jim clapper was making huge leaps
with rank speculation based on these
series of communications that stone was
having with senior Trump campaign
officials often in advance of WikiLeaks
releases emails stolen we know by Russia
what does that show to you is that
evidence in your view of coordination
between the Trump campaign and Russia
well it does to me I say that not as an
attorney but just as a layman and I
think clearly it does show a connection
coordination synchronization whatever
you want to call it okay nice try
nothing of the sort was indicated in the
indictment I mean this is where people
should just not go on TV if they don't
bother to read the indictment baseless
from former Director of National
Intelligence Jim clapper a man we might
remind you committed open perjury in
front of the Senate Intel committee
during the Obama years and faced zero
penalties where's the justice and that
tonight we're gonna expose men like that
and educate you the viewer along the way
now we put together an unbelievable
panel tonight to help us sort through it
all the political and legal aspects all
of this and of course the law
enforcement asked aspects regarding that
Elian Gonzalez style raid on Stone's
house earlier today saw Weissenberg
former deputy independent counsel in
whitewater Joe digenova
former US Attorney and Byron New York
for the political analysis chief
political correspondent for the
Washington Examiner and Fox News
contributor and someone who's done more
reporting than most people on the face
of the planet on this Russian
investigation saw now you read tonight
the indictment and what you just heard
from one of Roger Stone's lawyers tells
you what well he's acting like any good
defense lawyer would act I look at the
indictment and obviously if he really
did the strongest parts of the
indictment or the allegations of lying
directly to Congress the weakest part
has to do with the so called in
imitation of one of the others who was
testifying I look at the I look at the
indictment all of these indictments that
are for lying it's not that lying isn't
a serious crime like you say but in the
grand scheme of things if you're looking
at what is really being supposedly
ultimately investigated criminal
conspiracy we there's a term of art in
criminal defense world for these kinds
of charges it's two words the first word
is chicken and the last word ends in I T
and that's what most of these charges
are like as for the people who are who
are look it's not a Gestapo raid it is
not an alien Gonzalez raid in my opinion
but it was an inappropriate search it
was enough well I just heard right I
just forgot your stone himself say that
once they came once they came in and
arrested him they were very courteous it
would don't get me wrong
let's just not compare it to the Nazis
it was an inappropriate search and the
people who are saying that it was
appropriate because they had a search
warrant and he was going to destroy
evidence they could have searched him
before any indictment manner for number
two point number two he was released on
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
personal recognizance and I don't think
the Muller Frank challenged us so in
other words he's no flight he's no
flight risk at all and there's nothing
in the indictment that says that he was
destroying evidence so it's it's
ridiculous some of these comments yeah
well I mean the semantics aside Joe I
want to get your reaction to this this
is former CIA director your favorite
person Joe I can't believe you guys
aren't having drinks tonight John
Brennan making predictions for the next
two months there was an extensive effort
to try to influence the outcome of the
election that involved the Russians that
involved US persons and that may have
gone to the very top of the Trump
campaign I expect that over the next 60
days you're going to have
number of anti-air a fair number a
significant number of indictments Joe he
can read minds too well John Brennan was
part of a conspiracy to frame Donald
Trump he went to London he met with GCHQ
the NSA of the UK he arranged for false
intelligence to be fed back into the
United States to assist in acquiring
falsify the warrants
what John Brennan has to say really
doesn't matter but Laura before we move
away from it I want to say that the raid
this morning to arrest Roger stone was
one of the most vindictive
unprofessional actions ever conducted by
the US Department of Justice
Bob Muller all of his minions chris ray
rod Rosenstein and the acting Attorney
General Matt Whittaker should all be
ashamed of themselves
it was absolutely unnecessary it was
done for vindictive reasons it is the
beginning of the final degradation of
the FBI and the Department of Justice
and the fact that Chris ray and rod
Rosen Stein and Whitaker allowed this to
occur because they were aware of it they
did not stop it they knew it was going
to happen is an embarrassment to the
department of justice and it really
really makes it important that a very
serious person take over the department
millibar so that people like chris ray
can be held accountable like 29 agents I
mean I don't care if they bake cookies
or stuff I didn't get and brewed coffee
for four stone while once they got in
there it was the show for Santa listen
it was a total show 22 pages what is it
like 15 Outpost they needed to cover
Byron York yes you wrote a piece today
about it's saying that it's not so much
what's in the indictment they could have
written that thing in like three pages
by the way it's what's not in the
indictment explain that to the Fox
viewers please well what's not in the
indictment is an allegation that there
was a conspiracy between the Trump
campaign and Russia to fix the 2016
election that's just not there the other
that's really not there is evidence of
any knowledge beforehand of Roger stone
about what WikiLeaks was going to do the
most looked at paragraph and the whole
thing is that paragraph that says that
on July 22nd 2016 which is when the
Whitley quickie lease disclosures
happened then
the Trump campaign got in touch with
Roger stone and said what's going on
this was after the fact
suggests that there was not a collusion
scheme in place and running when that
happened I want to go now to solve
because salt when I hear Byron described
this I think to myself big deal okay big
deal like Roger stone wanted to find out
like when was the next stuff coming I
mean they were actually paying for
Russian sourced false phony salacious
information on Donald Trump that was
sourced in Russia they were paying a US
firm to to help disseminate it including
up to John McCain's office and everyone
else who had it and somehow this guy
Roger stone ends up arrested today
pre-dawn really I mean I'm surprised at
you Laura I just I just don't see why
you're not more excited about paragraph
12 or that indictment I mean I look on
MSNBC and I look on CNN and they're just
organic over it they're just look has
been used on the show I just want to say
in a night this is the this is the
paragraph that everybody is so excited
about because it talks about stone being
directed or asked by a senior member of
the Trump campaign to find out when the
next release is going to be and look
it's certainly if true is embarrassing
to the Trump campaign perhaps but but
but but but there's that think about
what they're saying they're saying that
somebody in the Trump campaign if true
learned about this there were there was
plenty of reporting about this and they
asked stone to find out when the next
release is going to be I'm sorry but
that alone is not any kind of a crime
and it's certainly not a conspiracy to
you hack the electoral system or to hack
somebody's computer or to accept
benefits from the Russian government it
just it just isn't but it's the
umpteenth indictment in this case where
people come on like Brennan and clapper
and say you're going to see the edge of
indictments you're gonna see a bunch of
indictments in the next two weeks and
it's part of Muller's master plan to
dribble out it's all part of the master
plan to dribble out the indictments to
dribble out the information and it's
just so far it's just not there I want
to play for you Laura
something yeah go ahead good Joe Joe
where you going next Laura although it's
very very important putting on top of
what solid you said every bit of
behavior of Roger stone and the other
people named in the indictment and the
Trump people with the exception of the
allegations of stone for lying
obstruction all the other behavior is
perfectly legal it doesn't matter if the
Trump people wanted to know when the
next that I stand on it that is a that
is a that is a legal question that is a
legal quit you can do that too it's
called political intelligence opera
search equipment yeah not Clinton's in
that statement about any of the people
involved in the Trump campaign or Roger
stone or person number one or person
number two is illegal except the line I
think they're done with me all right I
want to play something Byron this is
Rick Tyler tonight Lord today on MSNBC I
think it's really important for people
again across the country who are busy
they're in the kitchen they're making
dinner for their kids they hear bits and
pieces like oh my god this is this is
terrible like but I dealt with this as a
criminal defense lawyer reading these
indictments the people are freaking out
about it everything has to be put in
context and then you have the liberal
leaps of logic from never Trump errs
like Rick Tyler let's watch Roger stone
like Donald Trump is a political con man
who's showman stick has finally caught
up with him he's a professional
prevaricator it shouldn't be surprising
to anyone that he's now been indicted
for perjury he is a practitioner in the
dark are
of the political Dark Arts he's known
for dirty tricks and I think a lifetime
of this stick has finally caught up with
him
so now Byron New York apparently shtick
is it's a federal crime actually stone
did make problems for himself in this
way he bragged about all sorts of things
suggested that he had been in touch with
Julian Assange when he hadn't but he
said it publicly so after saying that
publicly he goes in front of the house
and they asked him about his public
statements except this time he's under
oath and maybe he doesn't tell the truth
about the whole thing he's certainly
accused of lying about all this so it
was his own brag that got him into this
trouble never brag good idea very
quickly so will there be another big
high-profile indictment coming out of
Muller's office or as David French said
tonight on National Review is this a
sign this whole thing has to wrap up I
have no idea but there's something that
no one's talking about what a democratic
town and what a Trump hating town DC is
and that's where Roger stone is going to
be tried in front of a jury of his
alleged peers and we should never forget
that it's a bad town for Republican
defendants that's an excellent point Joe
knows just a scooter libby just a
scooter libby yeah who had to have to
ultimately get pardoned because of what
happened to him
a guy's analysis legacy anywhere else
today on television thank you so much